c'est une belle salle ici
très bien mes chers collègues
chers collègues nous recevons cet
après-midi madame Charlotte cobel
secrétaire d'État auprès de la première
ministre chargé de l'enfance sur
l'application des lois réformant la
protection de l'enfance l'audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo madame la
ministre j'ai souligné il y a trois
semaines toute l'importance que notre
commission attache au suivi de
l'application des lots le Sénat
d'ailleurs modifié son règlement en 2019
pour confirme pour confier une mission
de suivi au rapporteur des projets
positions de loi examinés par le Sénat
et après préconiser récemment par la
voix du groupe de travail que pilotait
Pascal grenier de conforter encore cette
mission par le contrôle approfondi de
l'application des lois emblématiques
ainsi que cette année Bernard bonne a
été chargé d'une mission d'information
relative à l'application des lois
réformant la protection de l'enfance et
elles ont été successivement nombreuses
vous pouvez voir dans cette désignation
à la fois l'importance que
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
merci pour vos mots monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs je suis très heureuse
évidemment très engagée
sur cette réunion de cet après-midi
devant votre commission pour échanger
avec vous sur les sujets de l'enfant
c'est plus spécifiquement de la
protection de l'enfance et plus
particulièrement sur l'application de
cette audacieuse et ambitieuse loi du 7
février 2022 nous en avions déjà discuté
avec le sénateur bon qui vient derrière
deux grosses lois de 2007 et de 2016 qui
est elle-même interroge sur leur entrée
en vigueur je me permets d'ailleurs
d'avoir une petite précision sur la
façon dont on peut parler de
l'application des lois il y a évidemment
des la déclinaison réglementaire
et c'est l'enjeu de la loi du 7 février
2022 mais il y a bien sûr aussi la
réalité de la prise en compte des textes
par les opérateurs sur le terrain qui
est une ambition encore plus importante
et sur laquelle évidemment j'attends
beaucoup de la mission qui vous est
confiée puisqu'elle permettra peut-être
d'éclairer encore plus le gouvernement
sur la réalité de cette application
notamment des lois de 2007 et 2016 en
tout cas je l'avais déjà dit dans ma
précédente audition je suis très
attachée à la mise en oeuvre de cette
loi du 7 février 22 dès mon arrivée au
gouvernement je m'y suis attelé étant
entendu que vous l'auriez vous-même
évidemment constatez cette loi a été
adoptée tardivement dans le précédent
quinquennat à la fin du précédent
quinquennat c'est moi qui
à la fin du précédent
quinquennat et que par ailleurs
évidemment
les administrations toujours évidemment
très engagées se sont retrouvés dans
cette période un tout petit peu
particulière du calendrier électoral et
qu'il y a donc fallu attendre la
nomination du gouvernement 1 puis du
gouvernement 2 pour que les choses
s'enclenchent évidemment je voudrais
aussi quand même préciser quelque chose
c'est que j'y reviendrai ce texte est
très ambitieux et il comportait beaucoup
de renvois vers le pouvoir réglementaire
et j'y reviendrai c'est pas rien avec
énormément de dispositions qui est
compte tenu du calendrier de ce texte on
fait l'objet d'études d'impact rapide
trois petits points y compris dans leur
impact financier sur les départements et
dans ma démarche sur la mise en oeuvre
de cette loi j'ai repris beaucoup de
discussions avec les départements dans
un contexte je m'y attarderai aussi
extrêmement tendu sur la protection de
l'enfance ce qui explique une partie des
délais que vous avez soulignés très
légitime je me permets quand même en
proposiminaire pardonnez-moi puisque
j'ai l'occasion de m'exprimer devant
vous de vous faire un tout petit point
sur les cinq chantiers prioritaires qui
recouvrent en grande partie les enjeux
de ce texte et qui m'ont été assignés
par la première ministre j'avais eu
l'occasion d'en parler à l'occasion de
ma première audition dans le cas du
Conseil interministériel du comité
interministériel de l'enfance qui a été
réuni par la première ministre à l'issue
de la semaine des droits des enfants en
novembre dernier la première ministre
avait fixé 5 priorités la première la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
enfants j'annoncerai au mois de juin
prochain la continuité du plan de lutte
contre les violences faites aux enfants
tant cette réalité reste pregnante dans
notre pays la deuxième priorité c'était
l'égalité des chances et la priorité
faite à deux publics qui ont retrouvé la
thématique de ce jour de public les
enfants protégés donc être
particulièrement attentif à ce public et
les enfants en situation de handicap
vous savez qu'on a eu pas mal d'éléments
sur ce sujet là au cas dans le cadre de
la convention nationale du handicap qui
a eu lieu il y a quelques semaines
autour du président de la République la
troisième priorité c'est la protection
des enfants au numérique nous sommes
nous étions hier devant le devant votre
assemblée pour adopter un texte vous
savez qu'on a plusieurs textes en cours
vous en êtes saisis et puis nous aurons
le PGL porté par Jean-Noël Barrault au
mois de juillet devant votre assemblée
en priorité sur ce sujet tout à fait
essentiel la santé des enfants comme
quatrième priorité nous attendons les
conclusions de l'Est des Assises de la
santé des enfants avec énormément
d'attention vous le savez que notamment
la santé mentale des enfants nous
inquiète énormément les signaux
aujourd'hui sont extrêmement alertants
un peu partout et puis bien sûr le
service public de la petite enfance
Jean-Christophe Kombat a annoncé en
séance il y a quelques minutes des
annonces bientôt de la première mise sur
ce sujet là donc ces cinq chantiers
prioritaires sont en cours évidemment
d'action importante dans un travail
intermittel que je suis avec attention
le 15 juin prochain nous ferons un point
c'est moi qui présiderais le Conseil
international de l'enfance avec
l'ensemble des ministres concernés sur
ces cinq priorités fixées par par la
première ministre
donc sur la question de la loi du 7
février 2022 très rapidement je répète
c'est à nouveau un peu d'ailleurs comme
la loi 2007 et la loi 2016 cette loi
arrive après des mois et des mois de
concertation elle porte de nombreux
attentes de nombreux acteurs c'est la
richesse du chant de l'enfance on est
très nombreux à intervenir sur ce sujet
là autant les associations que les élus
que les acteurs institutionnels ont
porté auprès d'Adrien taquet énormément
d'attente et auprès vous bien sûr
sénateurs et auprès de l'assemblée de
nombreux attentes ce texte est très
riche il porte sur de nombreux sujets et
il renvoyait à de nombreux décret il a
été adopté extrêmement rapidement en fin
de quinquennat et je peux dire que pour
plusieurs raisons son impact financier a
été quand même un peu
évalué rapidement c'est dans ce contexte
que quand je suis arrivé en juin mais en
juin l'année dernière j'ai une attache
rapidement avec départements de France
et avec l'ensemble des présidents de
départements pour discuter avec eux des
modalités de mise en oeuvre d'un certain
nombre de décisions de dispositions
prises dans ce dans ce texte la première
des choses qui m'a paru important de
mettre en œuvre et c'est en œuvre et ça
ne relève pas du décret mais croyez moi
bien ça a pris pas mal d'énergie c'est
le baptême du Gyp France en France
protéger qui relève donc d'une
convention et donc pas d'un décret mais
je pense qu'il est important pour moi de
vous dire que ça fait partie de
l'application de ce texte ce GIP est une
originalité administrative madame la
Présidente puisque nous avons une
gouvernance partagée entre l'État et
quand je dis l'État c'est de nombreuses
directions qui viennent de nombreux
ministères sous la tutelle enfin sous la
houlette
la coordination de la direction générale
de la cohésion sociale mais nous avons
la justice l'éducation nationale la
santé qui sont représentées dans le
collège état nous avons le collège des
départements et on le sait même si
département de France assure une
animation très cohérente nous avons
une richesse des dispositifs de
protection de l'enfance d'un département
à l'autre et des approches différentes
d'un département à l'autre donc le
collège département a aussi sa richesse
et nous avons un collège d'associations
qui comporte des associations
j'allais dire engagés des associations
gestionnaires des associations de
premier concernés très important pour
nous des associations de famille cette
organène administratif non seulement à
comme ambition d'aider d'appuyer
l'ensemble des politiques publiques
qu'elle soit nationale ou qu'elle soit
territoriale mais elle a aussi pour
ambition enfin ce zip a pour ambition
d'apporter des éléments chiffrés d'être
centres de ressources en matière de
protection de l'enfance et il fallait
donc mettre au monde ce GIP un peu
particulier établir un budget que vous
avez bien voulu voter pour l'année 2023
et ça a été un exercice qui a pris une
partie de l'été voilà vous savez que ce
jeep héberge aussi le 119 et l'Agence
Française de l'Adoption puisque l'idée
de ce GIP était aussi de rapprocher le
sujet d'enfants sans danger et le sujet
d'adoption qu'on que ça conformément au
texte qui ont été pris d'ailleurs un
texte qui a été pris le même jour en
février 2022 la deuxième priorité que
j'ai mis et qui s'est traduit elle aussi
par du elle par un décret c'est la mise
en place des comités départementaux de
la protection de l'enfance dans le texte
il y a une expérimentation qui a été
prévue personnellement en qualité
directrice de la protection judiciaire
de la jeunesse et maintenant en qualité
de ministre je considère que c'est un
institution qui était indispensable à
mettre en oeuvre puisque c'est une
institution qui territorialement est
pilotée par le préfet en charge de la
coordination des services de l'État le
ou la le préfet la préfète le président
la présidente du conseil départemental
qui est bien sûr chef de fil en matière
de protection de l'enfance et en
présence de l'autorité judiciaire tant
l'autorité judiciaire a évidemment un
impact en matière de protection de
l'enfance ces comité départementaux ont
vocation vous le savez à non seulement
faire un état des lieux des besoins et
de l'offre et donc une stratégie de
l'offre de dispositifs de protection de
l'enfance un état des lieux et une
stratégie en matière de contrôle
extrêmement important en matière de
protection de l'enfance et bien
évidemment se saisir de tout autre sujet
y compris des sujets très concrets des
commissions
qu'a complexes ou 0 enfants sans
solution si vous préférez quelque chose
de plus positif des comptes des
commissions accompagnement à l'autonomie
très important pour les sorties de
protection de l'enfance et
éventuellement des commissions en lien
avec
l'accompagnement des professionnels
quand on sait qu'on a un sujet de
professionnel sur les territoires et
qu'il faut avoir une vision transversale
sur ces sujets là donc ces comités
départementaux le décret bien sûr a été
pris et j'en ai déjà installé pas tout
simple et les autres sont en cours
d'installation et j'ai pu mesurer
l'intérêt le plaisir c'est un mot
peut-être un peu excessif mais en tout
cas la grande attente et la grande
volonté l'ensemble des acteurs autour de
la table et évidemment ceux qui
n'étaient pas présents sur là ont tous
écrit en disant qu'il voulait être les
jours suivants donc je m'attends
beaucoup vous le savez je considère que
c'est une politique éminemment
territoriale et qu'il faut s'inscrire
dans le territoire et que ces comités
départementaux auront évidemment toute
leur place nous avons d'ailleurs relancé
les ensembles des départements qui n'ont
pas été candidats à l'expérimentation et
j'espère que nous allons pouvoir élargir
cette expérimentation je rêverais
d'avoir un département
ultramarin dans cette expérimentation ça
me paraîtrait quand même être important
d'avoir évidemment ces départements
représentés dans l'expérimentation voilà
je voulais dire que sur l'ensemble des
autres dispositions et je vais rentrer
dans le détail des des mesures qui
doivent être prises par décret ou qui
sont déjà prises par des craies
fait en sorte de consulter les
départements dans l'ensemble de mes
déplacements j'ai vu aujourd'hui plus de
30 départements sur le terrain et j'ai
interrogé sur un certain nombre de ses
décrets qui ont un fort impact pour les
départements mais n'oubliez pas aussi ce
qui explique un peu les délais de
d'adoption des décrets qui sont très
nombreux à être en Conseil d'État c'est
que nous devons consulter un certain
nombre d'instances au premier rang
desquels le Conseil national de
protection de l'enfance qui a été aussi
renouvelée par la loi qui devait aussi
faire l'objet d'un décret avant de
pouvoir rendre des avis sur ses propres
textes donc il y a eu aussi un peu un
mécanisme de délai pris par le Conseil
national de protection de l'enfance
qui très légitimement prend du temps
pour évaluer ses décrets à l'aune de
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant du droit
des familles des enjeux de protection de
l'enfance et il n'est pas toujours
facile de leur blesser les délais que
l'on laisse parfois un peu excessivement
au Conseil d'État on arrive à obtenir
des délais très bref du Conseil d'État
il n'est pas légitime que le Conseil
national de la protection de l'enfance
prenne du temps sur l'évaluation de ces
décrets alors dans les 42 articles qui
composaient la loi 14 prévoyaient des
renvois à des mesures d'application à
prendre par voie réglementaire
au total ça recouvrait 28 mesures voilà
aujourd'hui au premier au 1er mars 2023
24 mesures étaient actives en vertu de
la loi donc entrer formellement vigueur
une mesure étant avec entrée différé au
premier février 2024 une mesure envoyer
un décret à titre éventuel nous l'avons
sortis de notre liste parce que nous
considérons des facto que nous n'avons
pas besoin de décret et deux mesures ont
été mises hors compteur car il ne
s'agissait pas d'un décret d'application
de la loi ou le décret n'était pas
nécessaire
de nombreux décrets sont en cours de
procédure et doivent être publiés avant
l'été portant à 75% le taux
d'application de la loi au début de
l'été beaucoup sont dans le pape du
Conseil d'État
si décret d'applications ont été
publiées correspondant à 9 des 24
mesures identifiées dans les décrets
nous avons le décret sur les
informations préoccupantes
un qui porte sur un accroissement de
leur qualité fondé sur le référentiel de
la Haute Autorité de santé que vous avez
souhaité rendre de porter législatives
un autre qui permet le retour
d'informations à tous ceux qui ont
signalé ces deux décrets ont été pris un
décret très important avec un impact
financier non négligeable qui a justifie
des discussions assez importantes avec
les départements le décret relatif à la
rémunération des assistants familiaux
autant vous dire qu'il était essentiel
la courbe démographique des assistants
familiaux s'écrase je ne suis pas tout à
fait sûr que ce décret va inverser
l'engagement des familles à accueillir
des enfants confiés par la protection de
l'enfance en tout cas c'était un souhait
du législateur ce décret est pris et
reste à le mettre effectivement on
vigueur et à faire en sorte que ces
assistantes soient familiaux soient
payées ils le sont quand ils sont
salariés des départements on pourra y
revenir mais la question du financement
de ces mesures quand les assistants
familiaux sont rémunérés par des
associations il y a un petit peu un
délai à un petit des retards à
l'allumage si je peux me permettre sur
ces choses là puisque les départements
négocient des conventions de financement
avec un petit délai le décret prévoyant
l'expérimentation comme je vous l'ai dit
des conseils départementaux de la
protection de l'enfance a été pris et
les deux décrets instituant le Conseil
national de l'adoption et le Conseil
national de la protection de l'enfance
ont été prêts là aussi vous le savez que
la constitution de ces conseils exige
des concertations des discussions des
équilibres et parfois des réclamations
tout aussi légitime
15 mesures actives sont en attente de
décret d'application sur ces 15 mesures
9 ont déjà fait l'objet de concertation
avec les partis pour Nantes sont en
instance de publication où sont en cours
d'examen pour le par le Conseil d'État
il s'agit
du décret hôtel extrêmement sensible
permettez-moi de vous le dire nous
sommes et je reviendrai probablement en
conclusion dans un contexte de fortes
tension en matière de protection
d'enfance de toute façon vous avez lu la
presse comme moi et la prise
d'opposition du président sauvadé du
président du Département de
Seine-Maritime que nous avons reçu avec
le ministre de des affaires intérieures
et avec le garde des sceaux nous avons
aujourd'hui une triple pression sur le
dispositif de protection d'enfance une
augmentation des placements
d'enfants
qui habitent sur notre territoire par
les faits probablement de la crise covid
d'une meilleure prise en compte des
violences intrafamiliales mais aussi
peut-être de la politique des 1000
premiers jours qui fait qu'on place
beaucoup de nourrissons actuellement
donc une forte pression dans certains
départements plus de 30% d'Aug des
placements donc je dirais en protection
de l'enfance classique la reprise des
flux migratoires avec l'arrivée de
personnes se prétendants mineur non
accompagnés mais qui défacto sont très
clairement des mineurs non accompagnés
donc des petits voilà et puis évidemment
toute la pression du travail social qui
fait que les dispositifs même quand on a
de l'argent on a du mal à les armer
voilà donc ce décret sur les hôtels
notamment est un décret évidemment
fortement sensible et qui n'a pas du
tout été impacté en termes financier
des décrets sur dans le même impact
politique le décret relatif à la durée
de l'accueil provisoire d'urgence des
personnes se présentant comme mineur
d'un accompagné et le décret de la clé
de répartition
qui sont donc trois décrets éminemment
sensibles dans un contexte politique que
nous connaissions deux décrets ont fait
l'objet de concertation mais alors là de
concertation de fonds et sont en cours
de sortie du Conseil d'État et donc de
publications les décrets relatives au
parrainage mentorat et au tiers de
confiance pourquoi je vous présente ces
deux décrées ensemble parce que je ne me
paraissait important en prenant mes
fonctions
d'avoir une réflexion quand même
partagée avec l'ensemble des acteurs au
premier rang desquels des départements
sur cette fameuse politique du de
l'adulte référent
et de l'accompagnement des mineurs y
compris au-delà de leur sortie de
protection de l'enfance par des adultes
présents dans leur enfance et dans leur
dans leur avenir on sait que parmi les
choses que regrette les premiers
concernés quand ils ont 18
ou un peu plus à la fin de leur contrat
jeune majeur c'est de se retrouver seul
sans lien affectif voilà et donc cette
question du parrain du mentor du tiers
nid de confiance du placement du
référent azeux de l'éducateur
de cette adulte de ses adultes autour
des enfants a fait l'objet de beaucoup
de réflexion et qui nous a permis quand
même d'équilibrer ces trois décrets qui
sont en cours de publication trois
décrets un décret a été aussi beaucoup
discuté dans le cadre des travaux sur la
maltraitance et le décret modifiant les
projets d'établissement sur la
maltraitance voilà dans le cas d'aussi
des travaux qui ont été lancés de
manière très coordonnée par
Jean-Christophe combe sur la
maltraitance dans les établissements
médico-sociaux et sociaux et puis les
trois décrets qui sont portés par le
ministère de la justice mais qui n'en
font aucun bâton dit le décret sur la
médiation familiale les modalités de
recours à la violité en assistance
éducative et
relatives au droit accordé à une
stratoratoque par le juge des enfants
sur ces trois décrets on a eu un petit
pépin c'est que les consultations des
comités
ministériels qui sont indispensables
s'agissant de décret qui ont un impact
dans le travail des magistrats et des
fonctionnaires de justice ont été faits
auprès des anciens comités techniques
avant la réforme et le Conseil d'État
nous a recommandé de passer devant les
nouveaux CSA pour avoir des conseils à
jour entre guillemets donc les travaux
du Conseil d'État sont achevés on attend
dans les quelques jours la vie de les
conseils ont été réunis on attend les
conseils ça devrait sortir extrêmement
rapidement ce sont bien sûr des décrets
tout à fait essentiels et fortement
attendus je pense notamment à la
collégialité en assistance éducative
parmi les six mesures restantes dans
toute cette liste donc voilà d'où relève
d'un décret unique relative à la
création d'une base de données
nationales désagrément des assistants
familiaux et des assistants maternels
autant vous dire que nous sommes dans
des travaux riches avec la CNIL sur ce
type de décret avec des données des
bases de données donc les travaux sont
en cours évidemment on en est au stade
de ce qu'on appelle la IPD tous ces
jargons numériques que vous connaissez
aussi bien que moi et qui sont aussi
conduits avec ce nouveau Jeep qui va
porter évidemment ces deux bases de
données donc des travaux quand même
relativement important les dernières
mesures sont encore font encore l'objet
d'échanges techniques et d'un de cadre
dans des groupes de travail
voilà je suis pas pleinement engagée je
voulais dit à la demande de la première
ministre j'ai été extrêmement attentive
à être dans un dialogue très construit
avec les départements de France avec le
Jeep pour donner toute sa présence à ce
nouveau groupement d'intérêts publics
France en France protégés avec les
associations dont vous savez quels sont
extrêmement sensibles à ce qu'on les
écoute même si elles ont été entendues
pendant le temps de la loi on s'éclate à
partir réglementaire est aussi
importante tout ça dans un contexte de
fortes pression de protection de
l'enfance mais je peux dire qu'elle
était nous n'aurons pas à rougir des
travaux que nous aurons conduits pendant
cette première année merci madame la
Présidente
d'abord merci de toutes ces explications
je rappelle on avait envoyé à Madame la
Ministre une série des questions qui a
permis de répondre à une partie des
questions que nous voulons poser il est
vrai que aujourd'hui évaluer l'émission
à évaluer dans cette mission
l'application des lois de 2007 2016 2022
nous paraît important nous ne sommes
déplacés on a déjà fait pas mal
d'auditions la plupart des acteurs nous
ont dit en tout cas les trois lois
suffisent et vont assez loin par contre
avant éventuellement d'en reformuler une
autre il faut d'abord voir comment on
applique celles qui sont actuellement
votés par les parlements quand vous
disiez tout à l'heure que
entraîner un peu dans les décrets oui
c'est un peu le ressenti au niveau des
départements que les décrets ne sont pas
appliqués pas assez rapidement par
rapport à ce qu'on aurait souhaité et
effectivement vous dites qu'il faut
attendre la vie du CNPE
c'est peut-être important mais quand
même quoi la loi est votée les
parlementaires ont fait leur travail
l'application devrait se faire avec ou
sans la vie j'allais dire du CMP c'est
mieux de prendre leur avis mais c'est
quand même important
d'en tenir compte sur les cinq enjeux
dont vous aviez parlé tout à l'heure il
y a deux enjeux sur lesquels
effectivement la loi de 2022
donnait
son une volonté en tout cas
d'amélioration c'est lutte contre les
violences vous en avez parlé tout à
l'heure au niveau notamment du CRIP et
surtout
on a
recensé un problème en visitant un
département Eure-et-Loir avec Chantal
desseines que nous avons vu un des
départements du reste qui a qui est dans
l'expérimentation du comité de ce comité
de pilotage département très volontaire
ou à la limite en état des il y a c'est
un département assez vertueux parce que
les c'est vrai que beaucoup des
problèmes sont réglés et ça marcher
relativement bien dans ce département
mais
on a remarqué quand même qu'il y a qu'il
n'y a pas eu les
de moyens infectés comme il était prévu
notamment dans le cadre de l'hébergement
hôtelier notamment dans les prises en
compte des des jeunes de 18 à 21 ans
puisqu'il y a l'obligation effectivement
de les prendre en compte je sais que 50
millions d'euros ont été mis dans le cas
du PLFSS mais est-ce que vous pourrez
nous préciser à qui ils ont été
distribués sous quel
sous quelle forme enfin avec quel
condition dont il était mis en place on
a
dans ce dans ce département aussi on a
rencontré des services de l'État qui se
sont mobilisés mais est-ce que dans tous
les départements expérimentaux les
services de l'État se mob
ilisent aussi facilement aussi
rapidement avec autant de volonté et en
sachant qu'au niveau des juges pour
enfants
bon ils n'ont pas envie d'être
ils n'ont pas envie d'être convoqué mais
plutôt invité et je crois qu'il faudra
quand même absolument qu'au niveau des
différents ministères et notamment celui
de justice il y a une incitation forte
pour que la participation des juges pour
enfants le soir un peu systématiquement
et que la politique des juges qui est
quand même très différente d'un juge
pour enfant à l'autre soit un peu
identique par rapport à ce qui a été
décidé auparavant enfin qui est pas trop
de différence de traitement ce qui
arrive parfois on me disait tout à
l'heure que dans un département il y
avait des problèmes parce que par
difficulté relationnelle entre le
président du département et les juges
pour enfants il y avait un placement
systématique qui se faisait alors que le
département aurait souhaité peut-être
d'autres mesures
donc sur l'hébergement hôtelier vous
avez répondu les décrets ne sont pas
encore parus mais il faudra le mettre en
place rapidement beaucoup de
départements déjà mis en place avant
l'application de la loi des mesures pour
mettre en œuvre effectivement
un système qui permettrait d'accueillir
les enfants en dehors des hôtels
il faudra régler le problème des MNA
parce que c'est essentiellement le
problème des MNA qui qui complique un
peu la tâche des départements à la fois
sur le plan financier et à la fois sur
le plan hôtelier et je pense que il
faudra qu'on traite le problème parce
que c'est à la fois dans la loi
immigration c'est
à la fois dans l'enfance on sait que ce
sont des enfants mais à notre avis le
problème mais quand même différent au
niveau du traitement de ses enfants il
faudra quand même qu'on clarifie la
situation pour les départements les
départements et vous ne parlerez
probablement la répartition qui a été
faite ou pas dans les départements sur
ces mineurs en accompagné dans le flux
augmente considérablement depuis peu de
temps enfin depuis un an à peu près
après de l'épisode covid des
départements sont en grande difficulté à
cause de cette arrivée massive donc il
faudrait que vous nous en parliez sur le
sur le parrainage de proximité
effectivement est-ce que vous pensez que
l'application
de la part des juges de systématiquement
proposer un tiers de confiance digne de
confiance et faites
comme normalement c'est dans la loi
c'est-à-dire que c'est des juge une
petite pas la loi c'est un peu dommage
est-ce que le la personne de confiance
aussi dont on a parlé en dehors du
carnet de confiance mais la personne
confiance que le mineur peut désigner
est-ce qu'il y a des systématiquement
proposé parce que ça nous paraît
vraiment des mesures très importantes on
a parlé beaucoup de la présence de
l'avocat ou non en a l'impression
aujourd'hui que alors que c'était
peut-être pas le cas il y a un an et
demi on a l'impression que les juges
sont de plus en plus favorables à la
présence systématique de l'avocat pour
l'enfant discernant un discernant c'est
pas sept ans ça peut être un peu avant
ou autre il faudra peut-être aussi
préciser au niveau de enfin au niveau
des des juges au niveau des présidents
de départements si c'est un âge
très très précis les autres points en
dehors de toutes les questions je crois
qu'il sera intéressant d'avoir dans le
cadre de la mission il sera intéressant
si vous on peut avoir de la part des
services des différentes réponses aux
questions qui ont été posées sur les
danseurs les 50 millions
à un problème aussi qui a été
senti de la part du département
d'Eure-et-Loir dans lesquels nous sommes
allés c'est la la difficulté d'avoir des
titres de séjour et la la lenteur des
services de l'État oui je vois que vous
vous êtes bien au courant la lenteur des
services de l'État pour pour faire en
sorte que les jeunes avant l'âge de 18
ans et ou non un titre de séjour en
sachent sont dans la légalité ou pas et
qu'on puisse rapidement avoir une action
auprès d'eux et surtout au niveau
financier parce que tant qu'il n'y a pas
cette cette réponse
il y a un problème de financement qui
est problématique au niveau des
départements et si l'état pouvait aller
un petit peu plus rapidement je crois ça
simplifierait ce que nous en dit alors
ce que nous a dit le président du
département concerné
c'était hier en plus sur le
le CDE on avait en Eure-et-Loir aussi
que les services départementaux de
l'État volontaire était très volontaire
pour renforcer à l'avenir leur
coordination dans le champ de la
protection grâce à ce comité de
départemental de pilotage je pense que
vraiment c'est une un ajout de la part
du Sénat qui nous paraît extrêmement
important vous l'avez dit je pense qu'il
faudrait que rapidement la plupart des
départements s'engagent dans ce comité
de pilotage on a vu enfin on est
persuadé là il faudra encore faire en
sorte qu'il n'est pas trop de différence
ni entre les présidents de départements
ni entre les préfets qui sont
susceptibles de mettre cette disposition
en œuvre il faudrait vraiment qu'on
puisse avancer pour que tous les
services de l'État puissent participer
effectivement à la protection de
l'enfance sur les autres points bon je
crois
la dernière fois j'avais pas pu poser
les différentes questions par rapport à
cette mission cette fois j'ai un peu
plus de temps je ne poserai bien sûr pas
toutes les autres questions puisqu'elles
vous ont été envoyées mais je pense que
il sera important qu'on puisse échanger
et voir un peu
les la protection de l'enfance pour ne
vraiment au niveau du Sénat quelque
chose de très important qui n'est pas
assez pris en compte au niveau des
départements ou de certains départements
il n'y a pas c'est effectivement
politiquement et on l'a dit on l'a vu
c'est pas c'est pas très passionnant
pour beaucoup de personnes mais nous au
niveau du Sénat et au niveau de cette
commission en tout cas on est passionné
par ça il faut absolument qu'on puisse
déboucher sur des actions un peu plus
c'est quand même agaçant de dépenser
presque 10 milliards je crois 10
milliards à peu près par an avec des
résultats qui sont quand même
très moyen et on sait tous ceux on sait
que le pourcentage de ceux qui se
retrouvent dans la rue sortent souvent
de la soeur c'est que le pourcentage de
ceux qui se droguent sont souvent des
enfants qui sortent de Nasus donc il
faut absolument remédier combien c'était
100% des terroristes sont passés par 100
% des terroristes paraît-il serait passé
par la zone mais donc tous ces
phénomènes montrent que si on ne se
préoccupe pas de la protection d'enfance
beaucoup plus
c'est la créera des problèmes d'où
l'intérêt d'appliquer les lois les
appliquer complètement et d'aller le
plus rapidement possible parce que ça
fait quand même presque un an et demi
que la loi a été votée et
créer une application très tard un peu
même s'il y a eu un changement de
gouvernement même si un changement de
ministre il faut absolument qu'on puisse
avancer un peu rapidement sur ce sujet
merci madame la ministre
on va on va prendre la question de
Michel meunier aussi qui avait beaucoup
travaillé ces sujets notamment la loi de
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre hier soir on était au même
endroit on a passé une soirée je pense
très forte en émotion devant le
documentaire que diffusera France
Télévisions
sur au travers du portrait de Marie
Rabatel sur les enfants victimes d'abus
sexuels dans le médico-social enfin je
schématise et donc je me souviens
l'année dernière quand vous êtes venus
en novembre 2022 devant la commission je
vous avais déjà posé la question sur le
figeste c'est vrai qu'on a avancé ça
faisait suite aux travaux qu'on avait
fait avec d'autres collègues ici
notamment présidente des roches sur la
pédocriminalité en institution on avait
été très étonné d'entendre que le champ
est le domaine du handicap ne sentait
pas concernés alors donc hier on a on
redit l'omerta le déni voilà bon je
pense qu'il y a quand même des choses
qui qui avancent mais quand même on sait
que les enfants donc sont
des proies faciles pour les prédateurs
et parmi les prédateurs les auteurs de
violence il y a des professionnels ou en
tout cas des adultes bénévolent qui se
professionnelle ou bénévoles peu importe
qui sont attirés qui passent au travers
des mailles du filet donc voilà donc le
texte de
votre prédécesseur avait avancé
là-dessus suite aussi aux
recommandations qu'on avait fait sur le
figeste je vous avais interpellé donc ça
se mettait en place donc est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un peu plus est-ce
que c'est plus facile on sait que le
secteur médico-social notamment c'est
pas forcément sa préoccupation première
d'abord devant la pénurie de
professionnels ce qu'ils veulent c'est
des adultes en réponse au week-end pour
voir ou à la semaine à venir enfin bon
mais n'oubliez pas la protection de ses
enfants et soyons attentifs et toujours
exigeants de leur honorabilité
je vous avais donc posé la question
j'attends votre réponse même la ministre
aussi sur un type de professionnel
particulier je pense au chauffeur de
transport et transporteur d'enfants
porteurs de handicap vous savez pour
aller d'un établissement au domicile
voilà et est-ce que là aussi les choses
ont avancé puisque dans votre réponse
vous disiez que c'était en deuxième
temps que ça serait vu je comprends que
face à l'urgence il faut s'organiser
mais un an après où en est-on est-ce que
cette cette nécessaire vigilance sur la
protection des enfants est faite au
travers de cette recommandation
d'honorabilité des professionnels ou des
bénévoles autour de l'enfance
voilà après donc je ne reprends pas les
questions de Bernard bonne ce qu'on
entend dans les quelques auditions que
j'ai pu suivre avec le rapporteur c'est
que c'est pas forcément une histoire de
de loi tout y est dans la boîte il faut
maintenant actionner et agir et mettre
en oeuvre alors la question que j'ai
envie de vous poser c'est quel contrôle
il peut y avoir ça fait suite aussi à
l'autre travail qu'on a exercé dans un
autre domaine les EHPAD par exemple
comment avec quel moyen le contrôle est
exercée pour bien
voilà constater que la bienveillance est
là et que le traitement est
fait de façon correcte
je vous laisse déjà répondre peut-être
aux questions des rapporteur et de
n'importe quoi et puis ensuite on
prendra les collègues
d'abord une observation préalable mais
j'enfourge j'enfonce une porte ouverte
une vraie problématique de données en
matière de protection de l'enfance et
le nouveau Jeep en fait
va être évidemment pour moi un outil
extrêmement important pour remonter un
certain nombre de données et l'adresse
notre direction de statistiques à
récupérer une partie des données et doit
aussi structurer bien mieux les donner
en matière de protection d'enfance quand
on parle de données en matière de
protection de l'enfance pour moi il y a
deux grands enfin deux grands de
nouveaux 104 grandes opérateurs elle est
x départements qui ont souvent des
dispositifs différents les uns des
autres mais aussi l'autorité judiciaire
c'était un de mes combats sur lequel il
faut qu'on avance puisque les données
des juges des enfants sont
dans des applicatifs d'un autre temps
mais dans les mais ne sont pas
aujourd'hui dans les priorités du plan
numérique du ministère de la Justice qui
a fort à faire en matière numérique
c'est pas un reproche nécessairement
mais c'est vrai qu'on a un sujet
d'accolement de l'ensemble de ces
données y compris d'ailleurs des données
purement PJ sur le volet pénal puisque
nous restons extrêmement attentifs à ce
que le juge des enfants voit le parcours
de l'enfant dans sa complétude y compris
quand parfois l'enfant passe à l'acte
donc cette question des données pour moi
essentielles et nous permettra aussi de
bien mieux évaluer la
l'entrée enfin la mise en application
des lois 2007 2016 etc moi j'ai quand
même une donnée à vous donner de donner
importante en dépit des trois lois nous
restons à 80% de judiciarisation des
dossiers de protection de l'enfance
ce qui est évidemment quelque chose qui
ne peut que nous interroger sur les
pourquoi et comment au-delà du besoin de
recourir un juge qui est très prégnant
dans notre pays quoi qu'il en soit sa
traduit quelque chose et l'autre chose
qui est l'autre chiffre important c'est
en dépit des trois textes alors le
troisième doit être encore appréhendé et
le ministère de la Justice et la PJ
travail nous restons avec 60% de
placement et 40% de milieux ouverts dans
un chiffre qui reste constant constant
et voilà et qui à mon avis d'ailleurs
peut aller même en se dégradant si on
considère que le placement ne doit être
que l'exception par rapport au milieu
ouvert puisque comme je vous l'ai dit on
a un fort taux de placement actuellement
donc ces données pour moi elles sont
essentielles il faut qu'on les travaille
vous m'avez interpellé sur les enjeux du
CDPE je vous l'ai dit Monsieur c'est la
tort pour moi c'est tout à fait
essentiel parce que je pense que cette
cohérence de l'action elle doit se faire
au niveau du département
l'implication des préfets autant vous
dire que si on passe par les préfets
c'est que quand même eux-mêmes c'est la
force de notre pays quand on leur
demande évidemment un certain nombre de
choses et notamment quand ça vient aussi
d'une petite secrétaire d'État mais
rattaché à la première ministre ça a
quand même un impact relativement
important quoi qu'il en soit la réalité
aujourd'hui de nos préfectures c'est que
en matière de service elles sont
fortement peu dotées enfin voilà les
dettes qui ont récupéré toutes les
compétences que n'ont pas les autres
voilà et qui sont quand même extrêmement
largement compétences ont très peu de
moyens sur le champ de l'enfance champ
que je partage en deux la protection de
l'enfance et le champ aussi de l'enfance
mode de garde crèche etc pour donner un
exemple et je crois que je vous l'avais
donné la dernière fois
bouge du Rhône 0,80 ETPT dédié à
l'enfance à la préfecture des
Bouches-du-Rhône bon voilà donc
aujourd'hui c'est évidemment éminemment
insuffisant et ça fait partie
effectivement des demandes que j'avais
faites au PLF 2022 d'avoir des effectifs
and drets en dette et en dette peut-être
sur la partie contrôle voilà que je
renouvellerai en 2023 on en a eu
quelques-uns on est en train de les
répartir puisque on en a eu très peu
mais pour moi en tout cas les
départements qui sont volontaires et qui
ont été désignés pour l'expérimentation
doivent obtenir des renforts dans les
dettes c'est indispensable sinon on peut
pas avancer sur ces travaux côté
autorité judiciaire et je reviendrai sur
autorité judiciaire vaste sujet en
matière d'enfance j'avais précédemment
et on a reporté la demande de renforcer
les directions territoriales de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
pour renforcer leur implication
institutionnelle auprès des de
l'autorité judiciaire en matière
d'enfance vous avez insisté sur la
question de la richesse des magistrats
de la jeunesse et donc la richesse des
pratiques c'est bien sûr de
l'indépendance c'est comme vous parlez
de nuancier de magistrateur de
magistrates en disponibilité évidemment
je vais pas dire autre chose moi j'ai
surtout dans l'axe et je l'avais déjà
dans mes précédentes fonctions un décret
extrêmement clair qui dit que le
procureur de la République est en charge
de la politique de protection de
l'enfance et que la protection de la
Direction de la protection judiciaire
est en charge du pilotage des parquets
en matière de protection de l'enfance
voilà et donc c'est pour ça que moi j'ai
poussé pour que dans le décret le
procureur de la République soit donc le
vice-président de cet instant puisque le
luxateur n'avait pas souhaité en dépit
on influence à l'époque mais bon voilà
c'est mettre le procureur directement
dans la collégialité mais c'est pas
grave en tout cas le procureur est
vice-président
oui oui Non Non mais voilà mais bon vous
savez
là aussi la sensibilité quoi qu'il en
soit le procureur Elvis président de cet
instant le procureur ou la procureur
pour moi c'est extrêmement important
parce qu'il est par définition
distanciée des pratiques individuelles
et légitimes enfin légitime qui peuvent
faire l'objet de recours devant des
cours d'appel etc des magistrats du ciel
y compris des présidents de tribunaux
pour enfants qui certes ont un rôle de
coordination mais qui ont eux-mêmes un
cabinet et qui sont donc potentiellement
n'ont pas en conflit d'intérêt mais en
tout cas en
relation
opérationnelle avec les départements et
qui peuvent donc être un peu
schizophrène dans la politique de
protection de l'enfance et dans la
conduite de leur cabinet voilà donc moi
je tiens vraiment je tenais à ce que le
parquet reprenne sa place la PJJ a
demandé à crier progressivement la
relation avec les parquets pour les
mettre dans toutes les instances de
concertation en matière de protection de
l'enfance on a demandé des rapports des
rapports annuels qui monte
progressivement etc donc on a réinvesti
les parquets et pour moi c'est
extrêmement important je considère que
le procureur de la République et
l'interface indispensable entre les
autorités publiques et l'autorité
judiciaire du siège qui elle doit rester
dans son office du juge qui part
définition et de traiter des cas
individuels et d'avoir ces politiques en
essayant évidemment qu'elle ne soit pas
contradictoire les unes avec les autres
et il est appartient au procureur de
faire appel des décisions qui peuvent
être pas nécessairement éclairés par les
bonnes raisons sur les placements pas
les placements si c'est pour faire
pression sur le département c'est au
parquet de faire appel sur une décision
de placement qui n'est pas adaptée c'est
le rôle du parquet d'être coordonnateur
de ce type de politique publique et
vraiment j'y crois j'y crois et on nous
y veillerons et je vous le rappelle
grâce à un décret tutelle sur la PJJ sur
cet aspect de protection de l'enfance et
je sais que l'APG est très engagée dans
son dialogue avec l'ensemble des
magistrats mais en particulier avec les
parquets pour porter ses conseils
départementaux de la protection de
l'enfance
sur les sujets de de l'argent ni pour
les enfin des 50 millions d'euros et la
question de la façon dont on déploie le
budget qui est alloué au soutien d'une
politique publique qui est portée par
les départements en tout cas dans son
aspect chef de fila moi je crois
justement que c'est CDPE doivent être le
lieu où va se détermin vont se
déterminer les projets prioritaires les
actions prioritaires les actions sur
lequel les départements nous demandent
de les aider financièrement la
contractualisation qui a été mise en
place dans le précédent quinquennat qui
était une première brique tout à fait
indispensable et qui a porté beaucoup
d'améliorations en matière de protection
de l'enfance il faut aujourd'hui qu'elle
soit bien arrivée à une stratégie portée
collectivement par le territoire qui
priorisera ses actions en fonction de
son territoire voilà certains auront des
vrais problématiques de jeunes majeurs
dont ont des problématiques de
prostitution d'autres auront des
problématiques d'offres pour le handicap
que sais-je pour pouvoir effectivement
abonder correctement la
contractualisation et non pas saupoudrer
et non pas le faire un peu au cas par
cas en fonction des projets qui montent
des plus dynamiques etc pour moi le CDPE
doit être le lieu où se déterminera la
contractualisation l'implication du
préfet qui comme vous le savez porte les
contractualisations de l'État et
évidemment tout à fait essentiel et
c'est là où aussi il faut renforcer ses
services pour que finance stratégie
évaluation soit bien
alors si si bien sûr d'ores et déjà au
soutien des projets jeunes majeurs comme
je soutiens d'autres projets ça dépend
de ce que me demande les départements on
a une problématique et là je reviens une
problématique des données c'est que
quand il a fallu évaluer la question des
assistants de famille de familou et de
l'impact de la du décret quand il a
fallu évaluer l'impact du décret jeune
nageur dont j'ai pas parlé mais qui bien
sûr a été pris les départements
aujourd'hui sont peu capables d'évaluer
leur coûts ils vous disent a posteriori
ce que ça leur a coûté donc c'est 50
millions qu'on m'a alloués moi pour le
moment pardon non voilà je veux dire le
coup en fait est postérieur donc moi je
pense que les demandes vont me venir sur
la contractualisation 2024 puisque les
départements qui faisaient des Alpes des
contrats jeunes majeurs sur les financer
pardonnez-moi déjà et ils étaient quand
même assez nombreux à être engagés dans
ça et puis ceux qui étaient plus
récalcitrants vont se retrouver
peut-être avec des problématiques de
financement ils viendront sur la
contractualisation à année plus 4 en
tout cas moi c'est dans mon budget je
fais partie de ceux qui cherchent
évidemment à dépenser la ligne
sympathique mais quand même réduite qui
m'est allouée pour contribuer à
l'amélioration de la protection de
l'enfance et nous sommes extrêmement
vigilants à ce que toutes les demandes
2023 soit bien traitées et que je
dépense la totalité de mon budget sur
lequel j'ai récupéré effectivement les
50 ans millions dit jeunes majeurs mais
c'est toute la richesse mais aussi la
difficulté
de faire porter les projets enfin de
laisser les départements être à
l'initiative de cette politique et de
venir demander à l'état des soutiens et
de ne pas être
simplement dans la posture nous mettons
beaucoup d'argent et l'État n'est pas
d'argent d'abord vous savez que je
l'avais dit dans mon précédent ma
précédente audition et je veux pas être
trop longue nous travaillons sur un
jaune budgétaire pour que l'État aussi
mette en avant l'argent qu'il met au
bénéfice de la protection de l'enfance
on dit bien sûr que les départs
et j'en suis consciente les départements
mettent beaucoup d'argent et mettre de
l'argent en croissance dans la grande
majorité des départements il s'agit pas
aujourd'hui de dire que les départements
n'ont pas assez d'argent pour le coup le
ministre de la Justice en annonçant la
création de postes dans la justice des
mineurs mais aussi d’argent sur la
protection de l'enfance l'éducation
nationale que j'essaye de bien mobiliser
sur les parcours éducatifs des enfants
mais de l'argent sur la protection de
l'enfant donc c'est tout ça qu'il nous
faut compiler dans un jaune budgétaire
et c'est tout ça qu'il nous faut mieux
coordonner parce que aujourd'hui on a un
défaut de coordination entre les acteurs
santé éduque justice département pour ne
citer que on pourrait aussi parler de la
CAF sur un certain nombre de sujets
notamment les médiations familiales on
pourrait bien se parler de la CPAM sur
un certain nombre de sujets voilà tous
ces acteurs qui sont autour de la table
dont ces CDPE
le sujet mineur non accompagné
mériterait une audition spécifique si je
peux me permettre
si je peux me permettre d'abord parce
que c'est un sujet
que j'ai eu l'occasion de suivre depuis
de nombreuses années y compris depuis
2018 le dispositif etc c'est un sujet
sur lequel effectivement des textes
sont en cours de discussion dans le
cadre voilà il a il est de toute
évidence et que nous sommes
à nouveau dans une situation
où la question des mineurs non
accompagnés
fragilise ou mais en tension tout le
dispositif de protection de l'enfance
si j'en crois les informations qui
remontent aujourd'hui du département des
départements frontaliers côté italien il
nous faut aujourd'hui créer un foyer par
jour
alors il y a des discussions européennes
en matière de migration il y a des
discussions
bilatérales avec l'Italie il y a
évidemment des sujets qui dépassent ma
propre compétence je fais partie de
celles qui sont très engagées pour
fluidifier le parcours des mineurs non
accompagné une fois qu'ils sont pris en
compte dans la protection de l'enfance
ou même pris en compte par la protection
du cercle de la jeunesse pour les
quelques-uns qui sont dans inscrit dans
la délinquance on a un vrai enjeu de
dispositifs de sortie de dispositifs des
mineurs non accompagnés c'est un sujet
aujourd'hui en cours de discussion dans
un certain nombre d'un sens mais je suis
prête évidemment à revenir devant votre
commission pour en parler voilà la
question du criblage évidemment est un
sujet essentiel
on nous sommes aujourd'hui dans un
dispositif
opération d'abord je redis la loi est en
vigueur donc l'ensemble des personnes
qui doivent être tribuées en vertu de la
loi du 7 février 2001 leçon ce que nous
travaillons et ce sur quoi nous sommes
en train de finaliser avec la
constitution d'une équipe centralisée
pour l'ensemble du territoire national
et le dispositif que je vais vous
décrire et juste en face on attend juste
le lieu pour installer cette équipe ne
cherche qu'à fluidifier ce criblage qui
existe déjà on est bien d'accord parce
que il y a eu un petit débat dans des
craies qui ont été annulés etc ce
criblage existent déjà on cherche à
fluidifier par deux moyens avec un
certificat de probité comme vous pouvez
demander votre B3 par Internet les
personnes qui candidatent à des
fonctions telles qu'elles sont prévues
par la loi du 7 février 2022 demande
leur certificat de probité par internet
si ce certificat ne leur n'est pas
délivré automatiquement parce qu'il
n'est pas vierge là il nous faut une
action humaine qui sera opérée qui
aujourd'hui vous opérer dans les
préfectures et les départements de
manière
au fil de l'eau mais parfois avec du fil
de l'eau qui prend du retard nous
l'objectif et on est en passe de
stabiliser une équipe centralisée qui
fera ça à la chaîne bon c'est pas un
métier très attractif on se le dit aussi
donc c'est aussi pour ça que elle est
pas tout à fait positionnée cette cette
équipe mais l'idée que je quand il y a
ce qu'on appelle un hit avec le figest
ou avec le casier judiciaire il y ait
effectivement discussions humaines entre
le casier judiciaire et cette plateforme
pour confirmer que la personne ne peut
pas être recrutée ou pour au contraire
dire que compte tenu de l'ancienneté de
l'inscription officielle etc je vous
passe des règles extrêmement précises
mais en même temps assez
diverses il peut quand même être recruté
parce que c'est une inscription par
exemple on met très vite en figeste y
compris quand la condamnation n'est pas
définitive s'il a été acquitté ou s'il a
été relaxé voilà normalement voilà alors
vous avez év oqué madame les nouveaux
métiers non mais par contre c'est
opérant la question c'est de les faire
plus vite
mais il y en a qui passe
les personnes qui travaillent déjà alors
ça dépend de qui on parle quand on parle
fonction publique on remet pas à niveau
on est d'accord non mais voilà
tous ceux qui interviennent dans les
établissements ne sont pas aujourd'hui
contrôlés et quand il y a beaucoup
beaucoup d'intérimaires on nous a dit
hier que au niveau des services
préfectoraux il gère le flux mais il ne
gère pas les entrants
donc nous on a non mais
de toute façon on savait qu'on avait à
récupérer après il y a une question
aussi de relation mais ça pour le mot
pour le coup pour moi c'est des choses
qui peuvent être discutées aussi en CDPE
il y a une question d'exigence
aujourd'hui
c'est rien de dire quand même que les
entreprises d'intérim ont trouvé là de
quoi avoir des profits relativement
lucratifs dans le contexte qu'on connaît
pour moi aujourd'hui les grandes
associations les départements je mets un
peu à part les petites associations
doivent pouvoir exiger quand même que
les personnes qui sont voilà puis cette
tribulés que ça vienne avec la avec le
contrat d'intérim
il y a un moment aussi mais une fois
qu'on a dit ça on sait qu'on doit
rattraper c'est ce qui fait évidemment
que on entre pas encore des personnes
nouvelles mais j'appelle aussi votre
attention sur le fait et ça rejoint
évidemment
les interpellations que me fait
régulièrement l'héroïne du film d'hier
qui est extrêmement attentive à tout ce
qui se passe c'est qu'on m'a proposé
aussi par exemple à la suite d'une
affaire absolument tragique qui est
apparue dans dans les médias de criblés
aussi toutes les baby-sittes
non mais vous voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est à dire que globalement j'ai envie
de vous dire aussi
qu'il me
donc voilà donc en réalité les adultes
en contact avec les enfants je vous
passe je vous parle pas de QR code qui
se balade aussi sur nos sur nos médias
enfin je veux dire la question de
criblée l'ensemble des adultes
et si j'étais malicieux je mets deux je
ne suis pas parce que le sujet est
beaucoup trop grave me faut-il aussi
crier l'ensemble des familles voilà donc
si vous voulez moi je pense que en
matière en la matière en matière de
violence sexuelle en particulier puisque
c'est ça que nous visons
je suis plutôt en train de travailler et
ça je vous le dis ça sera ça fera partie
de ce que je présenterai au président
sur une campagne extrêmement choc en
disant est-ce qu'on a perdu le nord si
jamais on l'a jamais eu sur ce sujet là
parce que vu les chiffres si vous voulez
en réalité c'est toute la population
qu'il faut que je crible y compris les
gens qui ont des accidents de la route
et qui regardent des images
pédocrinelles quand même donc voilà je
veux dire toute la population doit
s'interroger aujourd'hui sur sa relation
à la sexualité sur sa relation à la
sexualité avec les enfants donc
franchement c'est pas un coup de colère
c'est franchement je suis estomaqué je
pensais avoir vu beaucoup de choses dans
mes fonctions précédentes quand vous
voyez les choses en macro
que nous livre la civise aujourd'hui
dont on sait qu'on n'est pas prêt de la
réalité ce que nous livre les médias ce
que nous livre les enquêteurs j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir un échange particulier
avec la chef de l'Office qui s'occupe de
toutes les images pédo criminelles elle
tient ses enquêteurs un an maximum
tellement ils sont écœurés bouleversés
dégoûtés de ce qu'ils voient donc je
bien sûr il faut pas lâcher sur le
criblage c'est une obligation mais je me
demande s'il faut pas cribler la
totalité des adultes de ce pays non mais
voilà bon pardonnez-moi il y a un moment
si j'ai un peu l'impression d'écoper à
la petite cuillère un phénomène de
société dont il faut se rendre compte et
voilà les violences aux enfants les
violences sexuelles sur les enfants il
faut que tout le monde me soutienne pour
vraiment crier haut et fort
ça suffit voilà j'en viens à me demander
si on sait pas structurel au cerveau
reptilien de l'humain mais voilà donc on
s'interroge aussi avec les pays
étrangers pour voir si c'est français
c'est pas français en tout cas on a un
vrai sujet de prise en compte et de
prise en considération de tout ça et on
ne peut pas banaliser les problématiques
porno les problématiques pédocriminelles
et tous ces sujets là on est aujourd'hui
dans un phénomène de société il faut
gérer le criblage mais pas que ça voilà
c'est ma réponse il n'empêche il faut
industrialiser le sujet parce qu'il y a
une forte attente
évidemment évidemment vous avez raison
mais je me permets de vous le dire quand
même parce que on a effectivement
effectivement un vrai sujet sur tout ça
[Musique]
mais là qu'est-ce que j'ai oublié
alors tiers de confiance bon je vous
l'ai dit les chiffres aujourd'hui on a
un vrai sujet placement pas placement
très clairement et la question du
recours enfin de l'évaluation de
l'existence d'un tiers de confiance fait
l'objet de travaux
à ce titre là et plus globalement à
l'APJ avec la méthode
éprouvée et pardonnez-moi je suis un
tout petit peu conflicté avec la PJ qui
est d'avoir quand même des groupes de
travail avec les magistrats et les
principaux acteurs et de s'appuyer sur
des expériences innovantes et des
pratiques innovantes pour infuser des
pratiques innovantes et embarquer la
richesse de nos enfants vers des
pratiques innovantes voilà aujourd'hui
sur cette question du tiend de confiance
effectivement de la place des familles
d'accueil de nouveau des sujets de ce
type là du placement et tout il y a une
forte réflexion
j'avais pensé que la réflexion qui avait
été portée sur le placement à l'APJ un
fusent un peu plus le placement en
protection de l'enfance ça fait partie
de nos objectifs d'aborder ça de manière
un peu transversale la chancellerie de
travail à la circulaire mais on voit
bien qu'on a globalement un sujet
transversale sur le placement on voit
qu'on a des placements en urgence des
placements protection qui empêchent
aujourd'hui le travail d'évaluation
serein nécessaire au tiers de confiance
et si je fais le lien que vous allez
trouver au déchets mais qui n'est pas
audacieux avec les problématiques de
criblage autant vous dire que les
enquêtes d'évaluation des tiennes de
confiance il faut qu'on les fasse bien
bon voilà donc ce sujet là pour nous
la Chancellerie est très
impliquée sur ça il recoupe globalement
cette problématique du placement du
placement en urgence dans un contexte
que je viens de vous dire à savoir 30%
de placement plus on est dans cette
problématique de la lutte contre les
violences intra familiales qui fait la
Une de tout de tous les travaux y
compris de ministre de la Justice et ma
collègue Isabelle Rome et donc des
placements dans le cadre des violences
intrafamilales enfin on a des mécanismes
qui font qu'on est aujourd'hui dans
plutôt dans les cordes sur le placement
et que il nous faut réfléchir quand même
sereinement dans ce contexte là à toutes
ces problématiques là de toute évidence
si vous me demandez si la loi est
appliquée non elle n'est pas appliquée
sur cette thématique là c'est une
évidence voilà c'est c'est et donc il
nous faut travailler à mon avis
très profondément pour pouvoir arriver
et évidemment mais le ministère de la
justice pourra vous compléter sur ce
sujet là plus facile le montera et le
parrainage de proximité parce que là on
est pas sur des sujets aussi structurant
que l'accompagnement je vous rappelle
évidemment que dès qu'on est dans les
sujets de confiance et placement on a le
chute d'exercices de l'autorité
parentale les actusuels enfin des facto
on est dans des enjeux extrêmement
importants ce n'est évidemment pas le
cas du parrainage et du mentorat là la
politique en matière de mentorail
parrainage est beaucoup plus développé
on va essayer de conventionner pour que
les départements entre dedans de manière
un peu plus systématique il considère
pas tous que c'est une priorité et je
peux le comprendre quand on a déjà des
problématiques de clos et couverts ce
qui est une des problématiques majeures
de la protection de l'enfance on est
souvent dans la logique vite on met en
protection sans construire
nécessairement autant qu'on le
souhaiterait les parcours des enfants
bien alors
leur en bureaux
Corinne ferait Chantal de Seine on va
couper les questions a et Annick
Jacquemet merci Madame
j'aimerais revenir sur le sujet des MNA
suite à un rapport d'ailleurs que nous
avions présenté avec trois autres
collègues en septembre 2020
il faut dire que la loi taquet avait
repris quelques unes de recommandations
et grâce à notre rapporteur qui avait
inclus dans la loi ici votée au Sénat
qui a été reprise à l'Assemblée
nationale j'aimerais revenir sur sur
deux points en ayant d'avoir un prélève
que c'est un sujet qu'il faut quand même
traiter de manière avec beaucoup
d'humanité mais aussi avec une certaine
fermeté et je vais revenir par rapport à
la discussion qu'on avait eu avec le
ministre taquet c'était et le Sénat
c'était d'éviter justement que alors on
va parler d'abord de migrants parce que
je crois que avant que on sache sur un
système mineur ou un majeur on va plutôt
parler de migrants donc avant que ces
personnes des fois qui on sait pas si
elles sont mineures ou majeures et pour
éviter
qu'à la rigueur il fasse le tour de
France c'est à dire qu'il soit des
nomades administratifs et on voyait que
ça existait malheureusement qui
changeait le département la loi taquet a
prévu un fichier national
on voit les premières informations que
l'on a sur ce fichier national et ma
première question certains départements
ne souhaitaient pas relater les
informations qui pouvaient avoir sur
j'allais dire les retours savoir si la
personne était réellement mineure ou
majeure donc existe-t-il encore quelques
départements qui refusent de collaborer
avec comme incidence pour eux dans la
loi c'est que si refuser le collaborer
ils avaient moins de financements
moins de financement ma deuxième
question c'est bon on voit depuis
quelques semaines que et notamment nous
avons tous été sollicités par
l'association du département de France
on a une recrudescence notamment
dans le sud de la France et plus
particulièrement la pomme maritime dans
le Gard c'est plutôt stable ça
augmentait il y a quelques temps mais là
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt stable la
problématique de l'hébergement d'urgence
un hôtel bon on sait que dans la loi
taquet normalement 2024 cela devrait
être interdit mais prenons l'exemple
prenons l'exemple des Alpes-Maritimes vu
le nombre de mineurs actuellement se
voit par comment 2024 on pourrait leur
interdire de placer de manière
temporaire en urgence dans des hôtels
qui peut être la seule solution même
temporaire donc j'aimerais aussi avoir
votre avis là dessus sur ces deux points
le fichier et l'hébergement d'urgence en
hôtel qui doivent être supprimés en 2024
sachant et j'en terminerai par là
j'apprécie beaucoup que je pense que la
présidente sera d'accord que on puisse
dans quelques semaines faire j'ai à dire
un point précis sur les mnaps je crois
que c'est celui qui nous concerne tous
peut-on envisager de réflexion qu'on a
en commun je crois qu'on est tous
attachés ici à ce que les départements
s'occupent de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
mais il y a un sujet spécifique des MNA
je crois qu'il faut ouvrir le débat
madame la ministre est-ce que c'est pas
un sujet qui doit être repris par l'État
et non plus laisser à la le financement
c'est donc la compétence
est-ce que c'est pas à l'état de s'en
occuper plutôt que de laisser cela à la
charge des départements qui perdent
j'allais dire le bénéfice de cette belle
compétence qui est l'aide sociale en
face
Elisabeth
merci madame la Présidente merci Madame
le Ministre pour l'ensemble de vos
réponses qui étaient très exhaustives je
vais m'arrêter à deux simples questions
puisqu'on est dans l'évaluation dans la
loi de 2016 il y avait le pécule qui
devait servir pour les jeunes sortants
de de l'aide sociale à l'enfance j'en ai
souvent parlé avec Madame Rossini alors
enfin ma collègue Laurence Rossignol
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque j'étais pas
très d'accord de détourner la location
de rentrée scolaire pour voilà faire un
pécule je pensais que c'était bien
d'avoir un pécule mais fallait peut-être
pas détourner maintenant je voudrais
savoir quel est le bilan et je pense
qu'elle serait d'accord d'avoir ce bilan
également et la deuxième question
c'était sur les décrets que vous avez
déjà
avancé sur les instants familiaux
concernant la dernière loi là celle du 7
février 2022 moi j'avais beaucoup
assisté sur
la mise en oeuvre de week-end ressources
pour justement soulager parfois les
assistants familiaux qui sont de moins
en moins nombreux et qui vont là de
moins en moins parce que effectivement
faut travailler avec
ses propres enfants et en même temps
faut assurer 7 jours sur 7 24 heures sur
24 et parfois on a besoin aussi d'être
seul avec ses propres enfants donc
c'était les deux points sur lesquels moi
je voulais m'attarder un petit peu merci
Corinne Ferret ensuite Chantal de Seine
Annick jacquemais et merci madame le
ministre je souhaitais vous interroger
sur une mission particulière qui est
celle des administrateurs adoc vous avez
indiqué donc le décret ou le décret se
rapprochement publié par rapport à cette
mission essentielle qui était renforcée
notamment dans la loi du 7 février 2022
mais si je peux me permettre d'être le
relais d'une interpellation de l'UDAF du
Calvados qui je pense est aussi celle de
l'ensemble du réseau une offre UDAF qui
s'inquiète du manque de moyens pour
exercer donc ces missions et les
indemnités on va dire pour ces mandats
qui sont vraiment très faibles donc je
rentrerai pas dans le détail mais les
conséquences pour cela ce sont que
plusieurs associations de notre
département en particulier ou dans les
départements limitrophes renoncent
exercer cette mission l'UDAF du Calvados
continue le faire mais elles sont elles
sont aussi pardon souvent sollicités
pour faire à la place de ces
associations qui nous le font plus et
donc il y a vraiment évidemment un
surcroît de travail et une impossibilité
à faire bien à exercer cette mission
encore une fois qui était essentielle
pour la protection de l'enfance donc je
voulais savoir si dans ce décret
peut-être que c'est pas le lieu mais en
tout cas soit dans ce degré est-ce que
des mesures sont prévues pour augmenter
les moyens alloués donc à cette mission
ou est-ce que cela pourrait être
envisagé dans le cadre d'un futur budget
Chantal de Seine et ensuite vous pourrez
répondre merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre je voulais revenir
sur notre déplacement en Eure-et-Loir
hier donc je suis élue et
le département est engagé dans
l'expérimentation des comités
départementaux proposition du Sénat le
département de Reynouard est en quelque
sorte pilote puisqu'il avait anticipé la
mise en place de ces comités
départementaux en particulier pour
traiter les situations complexes et ça
de par la volonté du président du
département et du préfet en place il
dénonçait jusqu'à maintenant en fait le
fonctionnement en silo et de ne pas
pouvoir traiter une situation un petit
peu complexe la justice sur place est
très coopérante et ça se passe plutôt
bien il y a quelques réserves du côté de
l'éducation nationale même si on fait
valoir que par exemple les enfants des
gens du voyage sont systématique
[Musique]
les magistrats ont quelquefois des
positions qui diffèrent certains disent
moi je représente l'intérêt de l'enfant
voilà et d'autres disons oui
effectivement si l'enfant est accompagné
et défendu par un avocat c'est plutôt
mieux donc je voulais savoir ce que vous
en pensez merci
pour terminer Annick jaguet merci
présidente merci madame la ministre je
vais peut-être sortir à peine du cadre
sur l'application des lois réformant la
protection de l'enfance mais je voudrais
profiter de votre présence pour vos
questionner sur deux sujets un rapport
de l'inspection générale de l'éducation
du sport et de la Recherche a rendu
public en septembre 2022 que seulement
15% des élèves avaient
effectivement leurs trois cours
d'éducation sexuelle dans les écoles or
ça serait l'occasion de les informer sur
la prévention des infections
sexuellement transmissibles les
sensibiliser à la contraception pour
éviter les grossesses indésirées et
construire une culture d'égalité du
respect mutuel entre les garçons et les
filles et aussi surtout lutter contre
les violences sexistes et sexuelles vous
avez largement détaillé tout à l'heure
le
encore UNICEF voilà alors je sais que le
gouvernement n'est pas resté inactif sur
ce sujet d'autre part on a vu dans le
cadre de la délégation des droits aux
femmes que deux tiers des enfants de
moins de 15 ans et un tiers des enfants
de moins de 9 ans avait accès librement
aux images pornographiques voilà je
voulais savoir si vous êtes en lien avec
le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et voilà je
voulais surtout attirer votre attention
sur ce sujet et la deuxième question que
je voulais vous poser dans le cadre de
l'OPEX j'ai eu un rapport à faire sur la
pollution lumineuse et j'ai été
sensibilisée par les travaux du docteur
ducanda qui a mis en évidence que les
écrans chez les enfants de moins de 6
ans pouvaient donner des troubles
neurologiques
un peu équivalent à ce qu'on trouve dans
l'autisme à savoir des troubles des
interactions et des troubles de la
motricité alors je sais pour avoir
posé déjà une question écrite à ce sujet
là
qui avait une campagne qui était prévue
pour informer les parents justement sur
la gestion d'Internet par rapport à
leurs enfants est-ce que vous en
profiteriez aussi pour les sensibiliser
aux dangers parce qu'en dehors de ces
troubles-là il y a aussi un problème de
myopie qui se développe de plus en plus
suite à l'usage trop précoce des écrans
numériques merci
alors dans l'ordre sur la question des
MNA et du fichier donc effectivement le
fichier en place depuis un certain temps
constatant que 10 départements et
uniquement d'idées départements n'y ont
pas recours le texte du 7 février 22 a
rendu obligatoire le recours à ce
fichier et interdit les doubles
évaluations puisque ce fichier avait
aussi vocation à la fois éviter le
nomadisme bien sûr et à éviter aussi que
des enfants soient évalués plusieurs
fois alors que que qu'il l'avait déjà
été précédemment ce décret
au Conseil d'État
il a un tout petit peu
patiné parce qu'en fait se poser la
question de savoir
puisqu'il repose sur une convention
signée entre le département et le préfet
pour organiser les modalités de cette
inscription au fichiers vous le savez
enfants doit être représenté etc et la
question de savoir
cuite la convention n'était pas signée
par le département en dépit de cette
obligation qui pouvait la signer etc a
fait l'objet débat et la profession du
gouvernement n'a pas été retenue par le
Conseil d'État donc on est obligé de se
recaler sur sur ce sur ce décret mais va
évidemment pas tarder à sortir il est
tout à fait essentiel on peut quand même
dire que ce fichier a permis très
clairement ce qui est d'ailleurs à
double tranchant bien sûr de limiter la
présentation de majeur dans le
dispositif ce qui était quand même un
objectif important parce que je le
répète mettre des majeurs avec des
mineurs reste quand même quelque chose
de extrêmement problématique
sur la question
du de l'hôtel permettez-moi d'abord de
vous dire que le
texte ne concerne pas les personnes se
prétendant mineur non accompagnés on est
d'accord l'interdiction elle porte sur
les mineurs mais pas sur les personnes
se prétendant millions d'incompagner
donc les la question des hôtels
mais je pense que je suis certaine ne
concerne pas les personnes en cours
d'évaluation et donc mise à l'abri
ça change pas
prise en charge c'est-à-dire que
l'interdiction de recours à l'hôtel ne
ça ne s'applique pas à cette fois là et
par ailleurs cette prise en charge est
financée par l'État voilà et donc cette
partie là elle a bien sûr un impact
physique politique
citoyen dans des communes et en
particulier les communes limitrophes des
frontières qui vont affluer évidemment
les réactions des hôtels etc tout ça
n'est pas satisfaisant mais simplement
pour dire que il faut quand même le dire
c'est financé par l'État et évidemment
la question de tel ne voilà je voulais
dire qu'aujourd'hui la question de
l'hôtel impacte
[Musique]
situation de handicap et de toute façon
pour de moi et à partir de
de 2024 de toute façon la question
d'urgence reste effectivement toujours
possible dans un délai qu'il reste
comment
non le
département en cas d'urgence c'est un
décret qui s'applique qui est applicable
au département
qui interdit l'hôtel mais qui prévoit
une clause d'urgence très très limité
voilà donc donc voilà donc en tout cas
c'est la teneur de ce décret de se
décret hôtel qui effectivement ne résout
pas en tout cas fondamentalement l'enjeu
des mineurs non accompagnés et
aujourd'hui l'enjeu des personnes se
prétendant mineur dans la compagnie qui
arrive à nos frontières mais voilà alors
vraiment sur cette question de la prise
en charge des mineurs non accompagnés
dans un débat éminemment complexe
je suis de votre avis il faut être à la
fois
très ferme sur les enjeux migratoires et
c'est pour ça que moi j'ai jamais eu
aucun état d'âme à ce qu'on soit
extrêmement vigilant à ce que les
personnes qui se prétendent à qui ne le
sont pas on soit très carré dans
l'organisation et qu'elle rejoignent les
dispositifs majeurs qui ne relèvent pas
de ma compétence et qu'on a encore des
efforts à faire en matière de
coordination entre les deux dispositifs
je vous le confirme s'agissant des
mineurs
bon il y a quelques semaines je suis
allée défendre la place de la France
dans le respect de la convention
internationale des droits des enfants je
crois qu'il faut qu'on soit aussi
attentif à quand même considérer un
enfant comme un enfant ce qui n'empêche
pas évidemment que l'État Vienne au
soutien des départements sur ces enjeux
là
l'enjeu des MNA il est extrêmement
transversal c'est un enjeu de relation
internationale et diplomatie d'acompa
enfin vous le connaissez bien je vais
faire de leçons à personne mais on sait
que Madame Colonna et mystère des
Affaires étrangères est fortement engagé
avec tous les pays de migration on a un
enjeu européen avec actuellement les
discussions autour du pacte migratoire
on a un enjeu national avec l'ensemble
des textes en matière de migration et
puis au sein de ça on a l'enjeu mineur
non accompagné je vous rejoins et
c'était mon préalable pour vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai parfaitement
conscience
que à la fois que je vais être ferme sur
nos engagements internationaux mais que
on peut faire basculer les enjeux de
protection de l'enfance pour l'ensemble
des enfants de France
de sur les territoires français avec ces
enjeux de mineur non accompagnés et que
l'État ne peut pas ne pas être aux côtés
des départements sur tous ces enjeux
j'en ai parfaitement conscience de là à
faire deux circuits différents quel que
soit la situation du mineur quelle que
soit voilà aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
quelque chose que je pousserais mais je
ne peux pas rester inactive aux côtés
des départements sur ces enjeux MNA
c'est une évidence y compris d'ailleurs
sur les enjeux hôtel je l'ai dit on est
en cours de réflexion si on supprime les
hôtels il faut quand même que les
collectivités locales au premier
rendez-vous qu'elle est municipalités
acceptent que soit créé sur leur
territoire j'ai envie de dire des
centres éducatifs fermés quand on
demande un certain nombre mais aussi des
centres qui accueillent des enfants
voilà non mais c'est pas pareil mais le
sujet pour avoir rencontré les
présidents des départements aujourd'hui
réquisitionner des lieux y compris quand
on est préfet ou demander à obtenir du
foncier ou demander à obtenir des
bâtiments pour les transformer pour le
mettre des mineurs non accompagné les
riverains sont pas ravis on le sait et
c'est vraiment la croix et la bannière
et moi je me pose la question dans le
cadre de nos enjeux et de nos règles
internationales et d'humanitaires de
d'avoir peut-être des moyens législatifs
qui permettent aux collectivités
territoriales et à l'état de pas avoir
nécessairement à négocié tout le temps
sur ces sujets là quand on a des vrais
enjeux migratoires actuellement si je ne
parle que du 06 le président du
département et le préfet ont quand même
fait état de leur grande difficulté y
compris d'avoir pouvoir mettre exécution
des réquisitions donc voilà il faut que
la solidarité elle dépasse évidemment
les départements ça engage l'État et ça
engage bien sûr tout le monde sur les
administrateurs adoptent évidemment ce
sujet n'est pas
nouveau n'est pas inconnu et je dirais à
tellement tarder que le garder sauts
s'en est emparé d'ailleurs en souhaitant
même changer le nom qu'il trouve
absolument illisible pour un enfant je
voudrais mon administrateur Adobe je
pense que ça veut pas dire grand chose
je suis assez de votre avis à part la
sonalité la tonalité qui réveille voilà
il a parlé de parrain judiciaire le
livre donc voilà et je sais qu'il y a un
groupe de travail extrêmement dynamique
c'est un sujet qui l'a pris en compte
personnellement et qu'il souhaite porter
politiquement il y a des sujets de
financement des sujets de facilitation
désignement de recrutement et aussi de
rôle ça renvoie donc le garder saut est
parfaitement saisi de ce sujet et
travaille intensément sur cette question
ça renvoie
au moins partiellement au sujet que vous
avez évoqué de la place de l'avocat en
protection de l'enfance voilà parce que
à nouveau et ça renvoie un peu à ma
question préalable de des adultes qui
entourent l'enfant qu'ils soient
victimes
de violence et en protection de
l'enfance ou qu'il soit uniquement en
protection de l'enfance c'est pour nous
un vrai sujet l'avocat
systématique en protection de l'enfance
c'est peut-être la dernière étape une
étape supplémentaire de transformation
du rôle du juge des enfants
moi j'ai interpellé dans plusieurs
cadres à la fois les jeux des enfants
mais surtout le mystère de la justice
pour réfléchir à ce sujet là de toute
évidence si des audiences sont
aujourd'hui composées de l'avocat de la
famille enfin des parents de l'avocat de
l'enfant vous aurez évidemment l'avocat
du département tant des conclusions de
travailleurs sociaux sont contestés par
les familles par les enfants par les
avocats eux-mêmes il faut lire les
réseaux sociaux et la façon dont je suis
interpellé sur la notion de placement
abusif pour voir que de toute façon
voilà donc ça veut dire que le juge des
enfants ne sera plus le juge tel qu'il a
été conçu par l'ordonnance de 45 général
de Gaulle et par les ordonnances de 58
en matière de protection de l'enfance
mais sera un juge arbitre des conflits
et des droits et des autres voilà
je pense que c'est une évalue évolution
qui doit être d'abord évidemment
travailler avec les magistrats eux-mêmes
et on voit bien qu'ils sont tiraillés
les uns et les autres dans l'évolution
de ce métier et qui doit être réfléchie
réfléchi avec évidemment la
représentation nationale et avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes parce
que c'est une évolution pour moi majeure
elle est majeure dans le rôle du GE elle
est aussi majeure dans un principe
auquel on tient tous le rôle du juge des
enfants sur le parcours de l'enfant et
je reviens au fait qu'on a tous été très
attachés à ce que le JO reste le je au
pénal et le JO aussi vide si on change
le sens de la procédure devant le JO
civil
il restera pas grand chose pour séparer
les deux Jo et pour correctionnaliser la
procédure pénale des mineurs au sens la
rente de plus en plus proche de celle
des majeures j'appelle votre attention
sur le fait que moi je ne suis pas
nécessairement je ne peux pas être seul
à porter ce sujet qui me paraît être un
sujet aussi éminemment important sur
l'office du juge sur l'office du juge
des enfants juge des enfants figurent
emblématiques de la magistrature en
figure emblématique de notre histoire
qui compte voilà en tout cas dans les
réflexions que nous avons puisqu'il y a
un PJ un PPL qui a été reposé à
l'Assemblée il me paraîtrait pas
inintéressant en tout cas de proposer la
désignation d'un d'un avocat quand il y
a une affaire pénale on court ou le
l'enfant est victime
qu'il soit victime de violence
familiales pardonnez-moi à titre
principal comme
réceptionnaire des violences ou bien à
titre de à titre de rythme en tant que
victime collatérale des victimes de la
de la maman ou du papa enfin bref des
victimes conjugales parce que là on se
rend compte qu'un certain besoin de
coordination qui peut être plus assumée
par le l'avocat serait une piste
et quelque chose de cohérent entre les
différents procès etc voilà c'est une
piste mais au-delà de ça vraiment
j'appelle votre attention sur le les
mouvements de tectoniques des plaques
qui font que le jus des enfants change
de mission et que on peut pas le faire
comme ça pardonner moi
personne aujourd'hui peut dire qu'il
faut pas d'avocat pour un enfant c'est
pas tenable même au regard du droit des
enfants mais il y a quand même des
enjeux derrière le pécule va se sujet
48% des enfants qui sortent de la zone
ont accès à ce pécule chiffre que nous
avons évalué après avoir constaté sur le
terrain que nous avions une multitude de
jeunes qui ne savaient pas qu'ils
avaient un pécule qui ne savait pas
comment demander leur pécule pour autant
qu'ils savaient un pécule et la CDC la
Caisse des Dépôts et Consignation qui ne
retrouvait pas les pécules par ailleurs
des pratiques extrêmement hétérogènes
des cafés
ou non la location de rentrée scolaire
ou parents s'il y a un lien suffisamment
fort qui laisse à penser que l'enfant
peut rentrer dans la famille bref donc
pardonnez-moi mais
des pratiques j'allais dire je risque
d'être un peu familière des pratiques
absolument hétérogènes qui justifie pour
moi de toute façon de remettre le
dispositif à plat je vous rejoins
parfaitement sur le fait que conclusion
ces enfants dont on sait que le parcours
scolaire et totalement
erratique au gré de leur placement etc
et aujourd'hui pas suffisamment pris en
compte par l'Éducation nationale d'où
l'importance de la place de l'équipe de
l'éducation nationale dans les CDPE je
me pose la question du fait de pourquoi
ces enfants n'ont pas le droit eux aussi
à leur basket et à leur cartable neuf à
leur entrée scolaire et pourquoi ils ont
pas le droit aussi à leur allocation de
rentrée scolaire comme tous les écoliers
et comme tous les collégiens et les
lycéens de France et effectivement la
question de l'allocation de ressources y
compris d'ailleurs des autres
allocations familiales au pécule de
l'enfant me paraît être un sujet pas
inintéressant à porter et nous y
travaillons dans le cadre de ces sujets
d'allocations de la branche famille et
d'équilibre des finances publiques aussi
mais vraiment on a un vrai sujet sur
cette histoire de pécule à la fois sur
le dispositif en lui-même et sur ce
qu'on veut faire et sur la facilité
qu'on doit donner à ces jeunes pour
s'insérer dans la vie une fois qu'ils
ont 18 ans
alors la PPL de Caroline janvier sur la
question des écrans je finirai juste par
ça la question des écrans évidemment que
la question dans les enjeux de la
protection des enfants une numériques il
y a bien sûr les infractions les ais etc
la question de l'utilisation des écrans
de l'addiction aux écrans des
conséquences physiques des conséquences
en termes d'acquisition du langage des
conséquences neurologiques qui sont plus
ou moins contestées donc je mets
comportementale certainement pas le fait
que nos gamins finalement font ça plus
que
un livre entre les mains
incontestablement la PPL de Caroline
janvier qui je crois n'est pas encore
inscrite mais qui a été adopté à
l'unanimité à l'Assemblée nationale et
assez complète elle parle d'une vraie
politique publique de santé en matière
d'écran elle vise à contraindre
évidemment les vendeurs d'écran à être
plus informatif sur les risques des
écrans elle vise aussi à ce que
l'ensemble des documents remis dans le
perdre non mais bon alors enfin encore
un logo mais quand même qui peut
paraître certes une puce dans la mare
enfin une goutte dans la marée mais
toutes les gouttes d'eau comptent voilà
l'information aussi au moment dans le
cadre de la politique des 1000 premiers
jours l'information plus visuelle dans
les carnets de santé etc il y a toute
une stratégie autour des écrans mais
elle vient cette PPL complétée toute une
politique que nous conduisons à
plusieurs au sein du gouvernement avec
Jean-Noël Barrault avec papendaye pour
sensibiliser responsabiliser les
familles sensibiliser responsabiliser
les enfants qui sont souvent les
meilleurs ambassadeurs même s'ils sont
quand même très addict aux écrans et
bien sûr l'ensemble des professionnels
les professionnels aussi de l'enfance
seront formés à la question des écrans
et aux impacts de l'écran
merci beaucoup madame la ministre pour
ce dialogue franc et passionné merci
beaucoup
la passion que vous mettez dans nos
échanges et les réponses on pourra donc
avoir tous les éléments
sur les enjeux pratiques sur les sujets
MNA
on verra sur les MNA si on fait pas un
effet une réunion spécifique une
audition spécifique avant l'été sans
aller jusqu'à une mission flash mais au
moins entendre les départements au moins
entendre les départements avec les
recrudescences voir avec les lois
puisque cette émission conjointe avec la
commission des lois qu'on arrive à faire
peut-être avant l'été avant
l'interruption de l'été en tout cas on a
bien conscience spécifique sur ce sujet
qui a besoin de réponse rapide et
urgente dans la situation actuelle de
moyen terme et de long terme de tout
évidence voilà c'est si je peux me
permettre on travaille sur ça en
particulier avec les départements
concernés
merci beaucoup